hot breath averse welcome back to hot
breath the show where you learn comedy
from the pros i am your host comedian
joel byers and the pro
we are learning from today he's been in
the game over 20 years
and despite coming from a family of
lawyers being struck by lightning shot
had his head busted open by a baseball
bat all those fun things his comedy
journey
has really taken him from being a
personal assistant to a social worker i
mean what this guy has created is a
brick by brick self-made career and that
is exactly what we aspire to create here
at hot breath are diy comedians
self-made comedians so this guy has the
blueprint and we are so
excited and honored to bring to the hot
breath verse the one and only
mr giannis papas ladies and gentlemen
give it up for your news
hello hello everybody hello i look like
a grizzled vet right now hair all messed
up gray in my beard i look like bull
durham i don't know if you know the
movie you know the movie because i know
right yeah for sure i know the movie
you're not dating yourself that much
yeah so i'm uh yeah i've been in the
game for a long time it's been a jagged
path
um
didn't you know i'm not the i'm not the
comic uh like most comics who started
and then never stopped like once they
started they just you know i started
stop started stop so
it's been a jagged pass oh how many i
know you stopped once for two years how
many times do you actually quit
i would say
i fully quit from i started in around
i uh fully quit from about 2 000 to 2005
like two and a half years
um and then i kind of did it often off
and on until i went full in 2008 i went
that's when i started really
uh
devoting myself to it quit my job lived
off my girlfriend which by the way if a
lot of young comics
are watching this they say what's what's
one of the big pieces of advice you can
give me one of is get a girlfriend with
a job and have no shame in having her
pay for you hey okay you gotta make some
you can't make homeless without breaking
a few eggs
she is the soldiers that you have to
sacrifice for the saving private ryan
which is your career
how bad did it get like having to like
live off of someone you're dating like
did it get kind of dicey like giannis
what are you doing here
yeah no she could sense it uh we lived
in a rent control apartment that my
friend grew up when i i'm from
parksville brooklyn so when parks love
guy gentry for it gentrify gentrify
but yeah my my buddy lived in what used
to be a bad area park slope he moved out
so me and my other buddy renovated his
house by ourselves so what didn't look
too renovated we lived in that rent
control apartment for eight years we
used to hide from the landlord but he
would not because he you know he he
suspected that my friend wasn't living
there whose family was in his name and
um so she moved in with us
my ex-girlfriend it was me my
ex-girlfriend a roommate and i think all
of our rent was 300 in park slope
brooklyn
when that apartment on the free market
would have went for about 25 hundo oh my
gosh so find a way guys find a way
that's the great thing about comedy is
like yeah
you got to really pave your own road you
can't look at anyone else's road too
much and figure it out that way you have
to kind of uh
pave your own
it's like driving at night you know with
the headlights on you can only see so
far ahead of you
yeah and something i've heard you say is
that like the internet and how it really
is like the greatest thing to happen to
independent artists and you've embraced
it since like
ditch film like you've been creating
your own content for a long time now
like one one of the questions uh one of
our comics here asked from a mitt wolf
is like
you know there's when we asked mark
norman about being a comedian he's like
there's so many other things and he's
like social media and branding and all
this like how how can comedians
how should comedians be leveraging the
internet to start really creating their
own path
yeah you have to think of yourselves
uh you have to think of yourself now as
an entrepreneur
uh you're your own marketer your own
producer your own writer your own
performer
uh your own grip editor etc you are the
network
that you used to try to get behind you
like uh there's nothing really to get
anymore there's only something to build
um
the internet uh even the streaming
services yeah
even the streaming services are internet
people like oh but netflix is still
vague it's like netflix is the internet
so the old hollywood model is gone you
even see schultz got a show on netflix
after doing his own thing so
you know your youtube channel your
patreon your your podcasts your skits
whatever it is your memes whatever
you're doing
stand up is just one of the things you
do now
um just be funny on whatever platform it
is even if it's on clubhouse before
before it completely collapses just be
funny like it's not about like oh man
you know like that east coast thing like
i'm going to sit in the back and watch
it tell and i want to be just like that
it's like that's only one aspect of what
we do now and um it's not the most
important one that's just the truth
you're you've really embraced it and
you're churning out a lot like do you do
you have a system a schedule a team
behind this like you got a lot of output
you're doing here
yeah um
you know uh i have uh
two guys that work for me one is my
producer jesse who uh was my partner in
ditch films when we did that ditch films
was yeah we were really early in the
game before schultz before tim before
before rogan evens podcast yeah take
that rogan
yeah take that in like the late 2000s
uh me and jesse formed the production
company called ditch we were doing like
user generated branded content for
companies like foot locker we were doing
videos and sketches and i had a few
characters that really got popular and i
started selling tickets but it was
really before the internet was kind of
fully monetized you could only really
cash in uh by doing the shows live and i
did
um but now obviously the internet is
completely fully monetized and a great
person to look to is tim dillon or
schultz
and how you know you can you can see
what tim is making now
i'll go so far as to say i don't even
think it's possible to make that money
in tv unless you're a massive name on a
massive hit and good luck with going for
that i mean that's like three or four
people who are gonna get lucky and get
that so there you go look at the money
tim's making and if you don't know what
that is
it's a lot of money and it's all
all due to his podcast it's all because
of his podcast so
those are the guys to look up to now
schultz rogan uh you know uh tim tiger
belly all you know bobby lee all the
guys are doing that and even some of the
youtube guys and meme guys and you know
the though you know even tank sinatra i
mean those guys are making a living so
if your goal is to make it in
entertainment
that's what you have to really consider
nowadays and you guys know that i mean
this is what young kids know that better
than old kids um
but it's actually doing it i mean you
know we're like okay yeah i need to be
online a lot i need to be posting
sketches i need voices or characters but
then it's like i mean even me you know
i'm 11 years in and last year i released
my own comedy special i was booked on a
tour like i was going to be a touring
headliner and then covet hits and i was
like i guess i gotta do social media and
then now now like half the time i just
looking at my phone like i don't even
know what i'm doing like like what am i
gonna do right now you know
well yeah a new a new job has emerged in
the field of comedy and that's the
that's the uh the tech guy the the guy
you gotta get yourself a guy who's
uh a guy who can edit or you become that
guy and all that stuff but you need a
camera guy you need
you need uh you know this and there's a
lot of people out there who are terrible
at comedy um some of you aren't
sociopaths and have a little
self-awareness i recommend to you guys
you have a little epiphany and you say
hey i'm not funny at all i love comedy
uh i'm lucky enough to live in this era
where you know what let me learn how to
do all that other [__] and let me join
someone who is funny and will become a
team and make content
who was the other guy on your team you
said you had the producer and who's the
other oh yeah and then i got i got uh i
got my boy drew um and he uh
you know he has aspirations to become a
comedian i good luck with daddy you know
i hope he does that but he also knows
how to do all the tech stuff so he's
sort of uh our intern now that uh works
with us so there's two of them jessie's
my producer and drew is the intern and
it's those two guys
you know they bang everything out they
make the clips they they record the
podcast they produce it they direct it i
sit down and i just [__] yell like a
madman that's my job is to to try to
tell jokes to feed my daughter's face so
you you're role
entertainer what the team's role one guy
is like the video and editor like as a
producer i'm what i'm really asking is
like okay
if i want to start taking this more
seriously and actually be proactive and
getting momentum
in this like online space like what what
do i need you know like who do i need
doing what type deal because i can be
funny and i i can you know i can work
hard but it's like what do i need in
place i guess
yeah you need a studio for your podcast
you need a green screen start doing
sketches you need a shooter somebody who
can shoot somebody who can edit uh
you're gonna have to start considering
you know uh
hiring people on an ad hoc basis to
create your flyers art designers things
like that that used to really be
difficult there's a lot of people who
that know how to do it now they're all
online uh once they start becoming a fan
of your podcast they reach out to you or
you can see them uh doing the work on
someone else's podcast you reach out to
them like this kid who makes all the
signs for the podcast uh i think his
name is muns ted muns uh he's a kid who
lives in vancouver and i know when we
made the history hyena sign i found him
because he had done a few other signs
and now he's doing like everyone signs
and he does them with tile and he lights
the back and they're amazing and so you
know people are really making their sets
look
high
tech now they're making them look really
good like real sex because there's real
money in it i mean advertisers now are
seeing
the numbers on podcasts and that those
numbers are getting better numbers in
television and so the ad dollars are
starting to go to those independent
producers make make no mistake about it
so you need to be like i said your own
set designer you got to be everything in
one gotcha um it used to be the
entertainment was a cruise ship and you
wanted a ticket on the cruise ship now
you got to buy yourself a speedboat
you know you got to be able to change
and adapt and churn things out things
move very quick now you can't sit there
and work on a script and write a show
that's with these [__] dumb people
who are 40 years old and that you know
they're sniffing the ass or some
producer in hollywood they sit there
they have a hundred meetings they
rewrite the show with a hundred opinions
by the time it comes out andrew schultz
has already done that
thing
a hundred times everyone has done it
already every joke you hear on snl has
been tweeted that's why this doesn't
work anymore that's why it's dead and
they just won't give up and i'll tell
you what i tell you how i know
entertainment the traditional
entertainment is dead i used to work in
the nightclub business when a club goes
out of business like right when it's
going out of business what they do is to
get their last cash grab before the
community board shuts them down or or
they just run out they'll do ethnic
themed nights
they'll do you know they'll they'll do a
latin night they'll do a hip-hop night
when a club has in new york city has
lost its cool factor that's what they do
right before they shut down it's a last
cash grab desperate move
to guilt you you walkness is like okay
we're woke so you if if you don't watch
us uh you're you're you're evil so
that's another marketing ploy to get you
to watch because that's all they got
because all the eyeball all the organic
eyeballs are truly online and all the
demographics that uh entertain that that
um
advertisers care about and companies
care about especially that's the most
important thing those demographics are
certainly online so as a comedian you
have to adapt to that now and get your
team together you got to have a team and
you're the ceo of that team and you got
to learn how to be a ceo real quick
which doesn't come easy to a comic um
but you have to do it and you're you're
the captain of your own speed boat and
[__] make sure there's gas in that
thing and go
yeah cause we've been i've been doing
this podcast for over five years we've
done over 300 interviews with comedians
and but it seems like
i don't it's it feels like it's like
comedy fans listen
but it seems like most comics now are
like they're being funny on a podcast
like i'm not necessarily funny on here
i'm interviewing comedians and learning
from them but it i don't know if the
numbers are reflecting the quality being
put out there like do you recommend i'm
coming to you for help you honest i've
been doing this 11 years i know it's
patience i know you've been we could
have just done this on a zoom call
yeah
but we get to stream it and now it's
content
right but yeah i was just trying to
think of like if i need to start my own
and just where i'm just funny and
showing my own personality or if it's
just continue on this and just keep
seeing it all the way through and being
patient you know
um
that's something you can answer here
i mean uh
i mean mark baron's not funny on his his
was an interview show too joe rogan's
not funny on his for the most part
and uh that works it's you gotta figure
it out that's the thing i mean i did a
bunch of podcasts that failed
i've done more podcasts that have failed
than the ones that are working so uh the
one with chris
yeah history hyenas was the first one to
work but uh you know i know you only
need one to work so if you want to try
something else maybe go for it i mean i
did one with justin silver about dogs
that sucked i did one with james madden
that sucked i did a solo one before when
i was living in miami doing that fusion
show that sucked
um am i missing any
i think that's it so i've done a couple
of failed ones yeah just keep yeah i
mean just keep going at the end of the
day yeah yeah history hyenas is one
we're all like what where'd they go like
we miss you
yeah
it's uh that's one of those things that
uh
you know it had a great run and it's a
classic and uh
now now people can watch my podcast long
days and chris has
you know chrissy chaos and uh and so
yeah i mean you know it's just three
years we had you know shows come to an
end so
with that one came to an end
how do you bounce back and i'm not
saying the show didn't bomb but like in
the in the psych the psychological
roller coaster of stand-up comedy like
how how have been able to navigate that
because no one's immune to like the
highs and lows how do you deal with
those lows and bouncing back
man they're hard that's hard it's only
something comics really understand
especially if you're sensitive there's
only two types of comments i've met
which is like
sociopaths like psychopath like they're
born cognitive they don't have any
feelings
and um they do you deal with that they
deal with that well they deal with it
better um like they do in every field
that's they rise usually they rise on
top of every business because they just
are unencumbered by feelings it's a real
advantage and then the other type of
comic is overly sensitive um and wants
the love and approval and stuff like
those are the only two types i've met um
and i think that's the only two types
that there are um i'm the latter um and
if i was the former i'd be lying and say
i was the latter anyway right right yeah
that's the modus operandi but it's very
difficult and only other comics get
you know i think the best thing to
always remember is you're not as good as
your best set you're not as bad as your
worst so don't get too excited when you
kill you know have some humility about
it because you know you've had the bad
ones and when you bomb remember that
you've had the good ones so you're not
as bad as that either it's just
that's how you try to stay even kill you
want to be more like jerry rice and less
like odell beckham jr adele beckham jr
treats every catch like he won the super
bowl you don't want to do that jerry
rice treats every catch like it's just
another catch and until the scoreboard
says win it doesn't matter and so that's
what you want to uh that's what you want
to emulate
yeah and just keep chopping wood stay
consistent
keep shopping with nobody better
to look at for that than mark norman
just a worker just
he's he goes in he's a great example of
someone who just consistently hits the
speed bag yep for sure and it's funny i
think a lot of times young comics are
like oh well i'll just get famous on the
internet before i even understand how to
be funny it's like some people are
trying to put the funny before the fame
nowadays
well hey i wouldn't recommend that
either whatever works for you if you can
put the fame before the funny do that
too yeah
and something you'll figure out the
funny
you did with your uh characters
i mean you've you developed so many
great characters and that's something
trent babb asked about a comic over in
california he's asking about your voices
and act outs are so good how do you come
up with them
um
god i don't know it they kind of happen
organically like um
i don't know um they're usually an
amalgamation of people
um
it's a vibe it's uh
and then i kind of work out the story
like for maurice
she was actually a character i did live
on stage for a while and that's how i
built her backstory and that's probably
why she hit the hardest maybe because
she was the most worked out so
there is something to that um you know
getting the character fully developed
what what her goal is what her backstory
is what her psychology is practicing it
the other ones that i've created lately
they've come up kind of organically
um
like derek from tallahassee and
he's sort of uh just he's a just so i
spent a year in florida living in miami
and you go you know you go that that
that miam that's a miami guy i mean i'm
sorry that's a florida guy outside of
miami or in some parts of miami that are
sort of from the old world miami and um
they're just different man and so it's
an amalgamation of things it's kind of
thought out
it's kind of a vibe i've experienced
obviously is you know like they say if
you want to do what you know like don't
try to do
what you don't know do what's closest to
you so the greek guy obviously i'm greek
uh maurice is uh you know puerto rican i
grew up around puerto ricans dating
puerto ricans i'm from new york it's
part of the culture in new york uh derek
i lived in miami so do what's closest to
you do what you know imitate if it's
gonna be your dad your mom your
girlfriend their family don't try to do
something foreign um do something that's
close to you unless you're an
impressionist then you know those guys
just watch impressions and do it so
yeah i've heard you say you'll work your
characters on stage and then film them
what are you doing when you're working
them on stage
working them on stage just riff with it
just ripping in that character
riffing that character get into the
psychology of that character that's
something
that is something i do it's like when i
and i've performed mauricio many times
for years live
uh for her fans and it's like i'm gone
like every thought i'm having
obviously there's a little there's uh
the wizard of oz is behind the curtain a
little bit but i am fully committed like
i'm thinking like she would think i'm
seeing like there's no one you can't be
embarrassed you have to give yourself
over to the character you can't say oh
i'm embarrassed to say this or think
this or you have to commit
and be that person you know be what they
would say be who they are and that's
hard in today's world because you know
unfortunately comics now
especially if you still care about tv
stuff are constantly thinking about what
you're saying which is sort of the
antithesis of what funny is so nobody
becomes a comic to watch what they say
nobody's a class clown because they said
the the right thing at the right time
what makes things funny is when you say
the thing that you'd probably be most
embarrassed to say or the thing that uh
is the wrong moment that you know
someone who's inappropriate would say so
you know maurice is inappropriate
maurice mr panos is inappropriate
they're over the top characters that if
you met them in real life would be like
this person is a little too extra so you
have to be willing to be extra and not
feel embarrassed about it so lose
yourself in the psychology of that
exaggerated character and forget your
inhibitions
it seems like that'll be easier when you
do that homework like asking what makes
them tick where are they from getting
all that context helps you to lose
yourself and then more
without a doubt you're right about that
without a doubt it's um what and
whatever your process is
however you do that work that's up to
you you can riff it and and and
obviously uh you know lower stake
circumstances
on your own podcast or at an open mic or
whatever
if that's your process thinking about it
beforehand when you're just sitting
around writing it down whatever your
process is
you know yeah absolutely you're right
and yeah there's two types of comics
i've come across and only two those who
write beforehand their jokes and those
who write on stage so whatever if you're
one of the two
you know and if you're a comic you
should figure that out
you should figure that out that's
something i feel like you should get out
of the way you don't want to realize
you're a guy who likes to write on stage
after years it's like what do you feel
more comfortable with like you know mark
norman obviously he'll do a little crowd
work pop but all his jokes are written
sam morrell's jokes are written
and
they're both there's not one is not
better than the other obviously
all great comics would do both but those
are the two approaches to stand up
comedy and you should figure out which
one you are as early as you can so you
can get good at it
a question cjwing is asking
is
how can you grow a solely internet-based
audience without just begging your
facebook friends to watch your video
oh well you know that's how you start
it's like it's like the bringer show for
your facebook videos i mean you know you
yeah
i used to text every person to my phone
with the links to the videos i used to
email them uh i'd post them i'd ask them
to show their friends
you got to uh you got to knock door to
door virtually you know
there's no way he's he's a his question
was upon him he answered his own
question yeah there is no way
you have to do that
wow and do you think it's like when it
comes to the format of content and
podcast specifically like
that
so many comics are just on there ranting
like it seems like if a comic's hearing
this and is like oh what should my
podcast be it seems like there should be
thought put into like the format why am
i doing the show who is it for type deal
and not just oh i'm silly i'll just go
and riff
yeah i mean the more you can pick a
theme or a niche now
uh you know the entertainment business
has exploded into a million pieces and
we're all kind of like touring bands
and everyone mistakes their piece for
the whole but it's not there's only like
four famous people left in the play it's
like matt damon matthew mcconaughey
george clooney and like leonardo
dicaprio and like you know denzel
washington and a few others everyone
else has their fan base and it's even
going to get more fractured so think of
yourself as a touring band
what's the niche you know there's so
many podcasts so
if you're just gonna riff a podcast two
dudes riffin you better be
as funny as me and chris were you know
what i'm saying like and even we had a
theme and i know that sounds cocky but
we were funny no you guys oh killed it
the chemistry was crazy
yeah so it's like you and even we had a
theme and a niche and like but we were i
mean you know make make no mistake we
were a comedy podcast so it was like we
kind of hung our hat on the historical
theme that we liked learning about but
if you're gonna do straight funny make
sure you're [__] funny
but
otherwise you're right think about it
beforehand the ru garbage guys are a
great example they got a nice show idea
so nowadays whatever your show idea is
don't go pitch it go do it
if it's a if it's a sh it doesn't have
to be a podcast do a web series you want
to do a half hour show [__] do it you
know do it just get the guy get the
shooters write it yourself you don't
need a budget you can shoot this [__]
you know when i used to shoot sketches
we would just rewrite it according to
how we could shoot it
so
whatever it is
do it
and then
if you want to pitch it somewhere show
that don't go in with the idea just do
it man do it yourself and you're
absolutely right try to do a little
preconceived work about what is the show
boom
um chris james asks stand-up is
susceptible to the pandemic clubhouse's
hype has come and gone tim dillon says
podcasting is already dying what's the
next frontier in comedy
me and tim talk about this all the time
podcasts podcasts won't die because it's
additive entertainment and um it's the
appropriate it's the appropriate uh the
appropriate format for
the technology
and the time the zeitgeist people like
to
add in their entertainment to what
they're already doing because there's so
many options that nobody's just gonna
sit down at eight o'clock to watch
destination tv they want to bring you to
the gym people don't want to be bored
for even one second so even when they're
on the toilet they want something to
watch i mean try going to take a [__]
without your phone you'll have a panic
attack so that's what the podcast is
that's what your instagram clips are
they're going nowhere the tim dillon
show's going nowhere what's going
somewhere is the jimmy fallon show
that's done that is over and you can
[__] sign and deliver that tim dillon
show is only on the rise and the reason
why he's probably saying that is because
he wants less competition because he's a
shrewd shrewd smart kid from long island
um a lot of podcasts will disappear but
there's only a few podcasts that are
really successful so um
you know don't let that discourage you
from starting a podcast and don't listen
to shrewd people like tim who are trying
to discourage you so they have less
competition people want to know why the
hyenas broke up it's because tim was
behind it to kill us so he didn't have
to share fans with us anymore the truth
comes out
um this one comes from mark pumpkin
but yeah clubhouse is done
you think clubhouse is done what makes
you say that yeah
well because i think it's like it was a
quick pandemic thing and it's uh
instagram it's the same thing as
instagram live just without the video so
i think at the end of the day it just
kind of ran its course people got
disinterested real quick because i know
that's the way i felt so i imagine
that's why their numbers are dropping
because everyone feels similar it's just
like oh you just kind of get sick of it
you know it's just uh listening to
people talk you can do that on gram you
could do that you know it was a good it
was a good pandemic uh app but yeah i
mean it's it's it's like it's user ship
has dropped off a cliff
so i assume that's not
oh yeah big time the numbers are bad no
i did not realize that okay i saw i saw
dan cook was poking around on there i
didn't know he was mr myspace so i
didn't know if he was onto something
there
yeah
well that was probably just his 20 year
old girlfriend using his screen name
he's still he's you know he's my
generation we pop in vhs's yeah he's
over disc yeah yeah yeah
uh mark pumpkin says i'm four years into
comedy i'm 32 but look 25 should i
pretend i'm younger than i am or am i a
sick person
i think you should just make that a joke
on stage
and leave it at that
it's not the premise for an entire
career yeah right yeah just do it as a
quick joke and then maybe get in shape
or i don't know
it's one of those you do about for maybe
once or twice and you're like all right
moving on
yeah
um
ball zone
his his profile picture is an actual
image of peter griffith's ball's chin so
i can only imagine what this question is
what are the new hot spot cities
that are on your radar for stand-up
comedy coming out of the pandemic
i mean that's obvious right
austin obviously
um
atlanta i think is a very underrated uh
common town we out here
yeah atlanta
um
i think those are the two i mean
chicago's not underrated everyone knows
i don't know that'll probably come back
new york will probably come back la will
come back but uh austin austin atlanta
nashville is probably coming up
um
depends man look at these uh
look at what these local politicians do
and on the in the coastal cities and if
they if they enact these tax breaks for
people
you know making a million combined in
new york you're gonna start to see
[__] comedy scenes pop up in arkansas
and all these red states where people
flee to to save a dollar because you
know at the end of the day
that's what really
dick takes uh people's politics is is
money
so if if people keep fleeing these big
cities you're gonna see more austin's
pop up
and that that's what we're seeing here
like at hot breath like once
once the pandemic kit
we just went online like i just focused
solely on this podcast building the
community and now there's comics around
the world in our facebook group we do a
daily writing club in there and like
feedback mics and all these things just
to help comics stay active and
accountable during this time but it is
there's like comics in like kansas who
are like i'll start a show
at the local bar like they're starting
to see oh i don't have to move to ellie
or new york i can start pursuing it now
totally totally absolutely i think um
the one thing about the pandemic i think
that won't change for sure is that
people have
really realized how
digital the economy is and how you don't
necessarily have to be
um i mean you know in a certain place i
mean commercial real estate is going to
be changed forever
forever ever i don't mean i don't know
if some of these companies will ever
use offices again because they why would
they they can say people are just as
efficient working remotely
um
why would they have why would they pay
that high rent in manhattan i don't know
we'll see
um
here's a
here's an interesting one and actually
as we're on the topic of this of like so
for someone like me
who's 11 years in i was like headlining
and now i'm like what now i mean to get
to get to the next level of my career is
it online figuring out what my voice is
on here with like sketches or characters
just starting to experiment with that is
that really kind of like
what should be next basically i think
it's not an either or thing i don't
think it's a one pronged answer it's um
it's it's everything you know continue
headlining continue doing stand-up uh
continue this podcast if you love it if
it's got a committed fan base start
another one if you want uh think of
think of something that speaks to your
strengths do that as a series
whatever it is find your strengths
what makes you funny and
make that into content
make that into content just you know and
usually it's the thing you enjoy the
most
it's the thing that when you do it it
doesn't feel like work
so just keep trying things until one of
them doesn't feel like work then people
will respond
beautiful
all right uh sam
asks how do you get into storytelling
without losing the audience i myself
lose interest after 30 seconds if i
can't picture the scenario should i just
be very detailed
dude i mean you know that's one of my
weaknesses storytelling it's a weakness
i feel the same way
uh
i'm too honest so i don't know how to
lie in a story like all the comedians
you tell are good storytellers they lie
uh this those things didn't happen
you know i mean you really think the
machine happened that way i mean
and that's not a knock it's like that's
how you tell a good story is by
embellishing or lying
so um that's not a
talent i have and storytelling is one of
my biggest weaknesses so i feel the same
way he feels and i would like advice
from somebody how to become a better
storyteller as well because it's not my
strength oh and sam also said shout out
to you joel i killed at my first open
mic last week and have learned a lot
from you and your guests
that's great we're doing it you do
you're doing the lord's work out here
amen we just need to pass around a tithe
that's all we need we just need to get a
tithe going because we're trying to walk
on water over here it is thin
so
robin
can i be too in your face when trying to
get booked for shows what's the proper
number of times to contact bookers
should i include a reel of material if
so how many minutes
that depends on the booker it depends on
your personality it's all sales man
mirror them if they feel annoyed back
off
you know but sometimes you can annoy
someone into giving you a spot and
giving you a chance
that is a total
individual that's different for
everybody there's no
i don't think there's one blanket
for sure way on how to do that just feel
it out and do
what you're good at
some people are better at networking do
that
do whatever it takes starting your own
rooms is also
amazing
um that's what i did um i didn't even
worry about getting booked i just went
and got i went and improved my game on
my own
i'm doing my own shows
um
you know find find a bar on a monday or
tuesday you know the drill that works
too so
i don't have a solid answer for that one
either
oh and chris james we just got a tithe
he just gave ten dollars for for our
dogecoin piggy bank he said this
interview is amazing
yo we're rich
you're rich
you don't want to split that you don't
get a fighter's fee you i promise you
yeah i mean and i don't believe in dodge
coins so i mean go spend that on elon
musk's [__]
dreams
no i'm going to spend this on wi-fi
don't worry about that yeah yeah
uh just a few more here we had
um
matt walker asking do you think it's a
good idea for new comics to move to
austin
yeah i do i do think that's a very good
idea
i do it seems to be where people are
congregating
obviously companies are moving this and
there's going to be people i assume what
comes next is it becomes a tourist
destination
maybe the becomes sort of like san
francisco you know you look at the
people who came out of san francisco and
that was the scene
uh you know allie louis katz
uh kevin shay i mean there's a bunch it
became a scene so yeah yeah i mean i
would
uh sam bass it's kind of the same line i
mean is it better to live on east coast
for doing open mics and getting started
or west coast
uh for for getting started i would say
east coast
i would say at least new york the at
least new york it used to be new york um
i'm sure it's gonna get right back to
that because
you can just the sheer number of shows
you can do in a night
is unbeatable so
um
i would put my money on new york or
austin
over la i wouldn't start in la hell no
yeah
yeah that's that's what was so dope
about starting in atlanta is like i mean
there's so many shows and they're so
diverse like i could go to a strip club
and then go do like a hipster bar and
then like go do like a coffee shop like
all in the same night it's just a great
way to develop
absolutely so yeah atlantis sounds like
a good spot too yeah atlanta land is a
good spot to develop for sure
um
michelle asks is it better to have a
youtube channel or your own website
youtube channel
yeah i mean you know what can you do
google won that game
second it's the world's second largest
search engine like yeah
youtube is i i realized the power of
youtube when i saw that social media
documentary about how they're engineered
to make us addicted to it or a social
dilemma and they talked about everyone's
just competing with youtube at the end
of the day and i was like oh that's
where it is you know yeah yeah youtube
for sure
you can't [__] with google
and uh cr this is a goodie uh
chris james can we get giannis advice
for handling hecklers perhaps with an
example
um you have to
shu you have to win
it's a
cut throat thing
do not be nice be funny
be merciless
be brutal
don't let them win the crowd over you
are you done
um
uh don't let them speak unless you feel
like they're gonna hang themselves and
you're confident you can
you can beat it
um shut them down don't let them know
you're encouraging it
um
hopefully you embarrass them into
silence
uh
if they do start to win get mean
get mean
if they start to win meaning if the
crowd is laughing
at what they're saying
more than what you're saying
don't
get flustered and walk off stage if
they're burning down the show you burn
it down even more because the set is
done anyway
so
i don't mean
yeah i just don't
don't be scared don't look weak
just burn it down
let the crowd know that
they ruined it
get get meaner
um
and just
stay in the pocket do not do not go like
uh stutter your words and like walk off
and let them win you can't it's a it's a
real knife fight at that point
and you gotta uh you know you don't want
to you're not playing ufc where there's
rules it's a street knife fight
and you don't want them to win
and if they do burn it down because they
already burnt it down by making the
crowd laugh so it's over anyway so
figure out a way to burn it down more
than they burnt it down for you so don't
start mean just start a little
conversational and speaking with them
[Music]
i think malcolm x in this situation by
any means necessary win that you have to
you have to win that now examples
there's too many for me to think of
um
it happens all the time it's something
comics got to deal with and uh you
should have a bag of tricks
you should have some go-to
uh cuts some digs
um
and what i mean by be mean is like don't
go like personal i'm just saying mean
jokes like if you have some mean ones
you know it's like i've seen i've seen
jim gaffigan get mean i've seen gary
goldman get mean
i've you know you know you just
yeah in fact they get the meanest
because they require the most attention
and silence and orderly crowd so
um
you can't let a heckler steal the
limelight and you can't let them win
if they ruin the show by saying
something funnier than you in the crowds
likes it you got no choice but to burn
the whole thing down you know what i
mean it's like you can't give them that
house
either it's your house or it's nobody's
house it's not gonna be his house so
that's my advice
burn it down
so if you like ended a show on a heckler
you just freak out on them and then just
leave
i make the crowd go ooh
if they get funny and say something
funny
um that beats me which has very rarely
happened i'm good with heckler i'd say
you know some people are better at it
i'm kind of good in the fly train
yourself to be good in the fly have some
stock it's good to have some stock
responses if you need that
um but if i've gotten the times that
i've like gotten beaten yeah i just kind
of uh
i just kind of burned the rest of the
set down and just
in other words i didn't go back to my
jokes i guess that's what i'm trying to
say the set is over like if they start
getting laughs and the crowd gets behind
them
keep going at them
you have the microphone so you can
always be louder
so don't go back into your set it's over
the crowd likes them
it's and now it they the person has
you've lost
so now you have to burn it down you have
to make the crowd pay the crowd side
with them so [__] the crowd [__] them
[__] everybody you're leaving guns
blazing and you're going out
cutting him off don't let him speak when
he starts speaking you cut him off
you tell him this sucks you tell him the
room suck you tell him [__] you that's
what i mean by burn it down like you
guys suck you don't deserve it blah blah
blah [__] this guy try to think of
something mean do a lot because you're
louder than him one of them will hit you
know he's speaking they can't hear him
so you just go you're a [__] idiot
look at those jeans look at you look at
you're probably one of those people
don't pause burn it down that's what i
that's what i meant i guess that's uh i
wasn't being specific on what you do
that's what you do that's the most
impact
you've gotten in this interview is
talking about hecklers you're like you
gotta yeah because they [__] suck
they think they're helping a show i mean
you know you don't get beat by a hacker
where he gets the crowd laughing then
you go hahaha yeah man that was a good
one all right anyway so let me get back
to the material um you know no the crowd
they don't they're not into it anymore
yep he's he's emboldened and you look
weak can't let that happen
yeah that's something robin said yes
robin posted in our facebook group a
video of rocky dale davis recently
dealing with a heckler very well
if um anybody watching this is curious
about that
um yeah but uh don't start mean start
start trying to you know be funny try to
be funny and deal with your funny and
shut him up get the crowd laughing
and uh hopefully you embarrass him into
silence which is often what happens yeah
because the crowd is on your side like
they want you to win but if the heckler
starts then it becomes a game if if you
don't just extinguish it quickly it can
it can escalate quickly you want to
extinguish it quickly it is a threat it
is a threat to your show it's a threat
to everything if they're talking and not
heckling if they're disruptive
ask to have them removed you know that's
another thing that's what i mean by
burning it down like you know don't go
haha that was a good one don't agree
with the crowd if they you know it's
like you can do like a smirk and then be
like okay now you got to leave now
because you're disruptive like don't let
the heckler be funnier than you at all
costs you have to be a heartless [__]
stone cold killer to stamp out that
threat
[Music]
yeah
do you what's your opinion sean
lindbaugh lindblad
said what's your opinion on improv
groups and how do you think they can
help us with stand-up
um
improv is amazing when it's good it's
rarely good mostly sucks but when it's
good it's amazing
um
they can teach you how to think on your
feet more
perform in the moment more which is a
good tool for live performance
you know especially if you're good at
that
so obviously that
[Music]
duh trent babb said you have a checklist
for new jokes to
for each new joke to make sure it's
fleshed out
yeah
yeah kind of i mean i don't know if i'd
call it a checklist but
you know something uh
tense amount uh to that
it's um you know i i have uh
i write them down like oh these are new
ones and then i really start to hammer
them and um
the way i write is i don't do every line
but i will have parts of the joke that
signify the beginning middle and end and
so my whole goal with the joke is to
know the beginning middle and end
so um
i'll have the premise first then it'll
start to form and then it's fully cooked
when it has a middle and it has a big
pop at the end i want you know
you don't want it to like die like that
i want that last laugh of the joke to be
the biggest that's the goal
so sometimes it's like maybe in the
middle or the beginning and you have to
figure out how to work towards that
laugh instead of starting there
absolutely you couldn't set it better
yeah like sometimes you the first time i
tell it the big laugh will be at the
beginning
and that's the goal going like okay now
i got to figure out what the joke is to
put that laugh at the end of the joke
okay totally
are you more like writing on stage or do
you pen to paper
all all on stage all on stage i'll go
with an idea that either hits me while
i'm up there or i've thought of before
and i will completely write it on stage
conversationally
and um i will work it out and punch it
up on stage
um and or off in my head and then put it
on stage so all the writing is done on
stage and then when it's fully cooked
i'll know it and i do have a checklist
where i'll have the you know a couple of
words that signify what the joke is
and then towards the beginning of it
i'll i'll have when the middle forms
i'll put that in and then the end i'll
put that in and then that's it and then
after that i just put the premise
because i know it but
that's the checklist that's how i do it
it's like i'm
my format is i'm always looking for a
middle and an end
so that and and and i write that down
and i keep track of that and then it's
fully cooked and ready to ready to come
out of the oven when i get that laugh at
the end and it also paces in the middle
a little bit i want a few laughs in the
middle i want to laugh to get into it
and i want the biggest laugh at the end
do you have an example that you could
like walk us through
yeah like i'll take any joke uh that i
have like um
you know i'll take uh okay like this um
this divorce joke i used to have just
because the first one i thought of
um or or the soccer joke um so it's like
i'd start with like the premise this old
soccer joke i have like you know i tried
to like soccer i did you know it's just
nobody
scores um
you know americans will be like scoring
it's like the most thing that'll the
most that'll happen in soccer every 10
minutes they'll almost be a goal so i
get a little laugh at the beginning like
saying like soccer sucks right so some
people will laugh whatever i'll rift
that part or something whatever
feeling whatever the show is
um nobody scores americans like scoring
some passion there
and then i will go uh you know then i'll
get uh you know the only uh half what
will happen the only thing that happens
every 10 minutes there will almost be a
goal someone almost scores right set up
right there that's why soccer fans are
so violent that's why they're soccer
hooligans because they never get a
chance to celebrate at the game so
they're all pent up and frustrated and
then they leave the match and punch each
other in the face because they just had
gold blue balls for two and a half hours
boom then i'm gonna laugh there then i
go the only thing that'll make soccer
fun is if there was a blind guy in the
sidelines with a gun and he was just
randomly firing onto the field boom boom
boom so laugh there and then i go into
the crescendo then i go
you know europeans they hate when you
criticize soccer you know and then i'll
do an impersonation of a swedish guy or
german guy you don't like soccer because
you're american and you're not good at
it whatever and then i go really magnus
you know lucky you are american athletes
not fun like soccer and this is the last
chunk the biggest laughs
um do you know what happened if black
americans started playing soccer can you
imagine like you know our athletes there
would be no world cup you know and then
i go can you imagine okay it's the first
game
first italy here comes guido he passes
into ouija luigi back to guido but oh my
god here comes ladain lee and tomlinson
you know he's juggling six soccer balls
he passes it to lebron james who kicks a
goal into another soccer stadium in
another country to win four games at the
same time and at that point it's like
it's laughter it's laughter and that's
the you know it's all the same premise
and i found each little bits of that
until it was all plugged in obviously i
can't put the act out in the middle i
can't put that whole black imagine if
black kids love
soccer like they do you know you know
what the premise is i can't put that in
the middle because it has a big act out
to it it has a crescendo of laughs so i
feel a couple pacing a couple of pacing
punches with a blind guy in the
sidelines the uh you know the
gold blue balls in the middle and then
the little chuckles and premise up top
and there's the joke man and when i
started that i probably started with
um
i started with and i remember actually i
started with the line in my head going i
know why soccer fans are so violent
because nobody scores so they're
frustrated so that's how that joke
started okay so
that was the only laugh i had and i was
like all right and so that light that
laugh
ended up being in the middle and it's a
big laugh
um
and then the bigger i found were the
bigger ones at the end and it turned
into a bit and i pushed that one farther
back developed it and then found like a
real nice christian you know ending for
it and i used to close on that joke
actually for a while because it used to
it used to hit so big towards the end
and you you perform it on stage and then
like record it and review it
i should record it it would make it
quicker probably but i don't because
i just memory yeah recording it's great
though because you
you i just can't stand to hear myself
uh and i don't have the patience to sit
through the show again
so uh i forget a lot of [__] it takes a
lot longer but i do recommend recording
it yeah put your especially with
technology now your iphone or your just
record it listen to it later for sure i
know louis does that
i know a lot of guys who write on stage
do that you know louie writes on stage i
believe and it's like it it's just it's
great to do it that way
oh and sam bass gave us a dollar for
that look at that eleven dollars we
rolling shouty
yeah uh so maybe just two dos mas here
real quick john mulhill what do you
think
of it's all been done before there's
nothing new under the sun mentality
yeah i can't argue that um
you know it's like it's a finite
universe um
there's only a certain amount of chords
in music
it's all about um
your experience i think is big right now
um and that doesn't go to say it's got
to be all stories about your life but
you know there's only a certain amount
of premises yes you just have to find
what
your melody is for that premise you know
you can't steal premises
um you can steal jokes
so nobody can say hey man i you know you
told the divorce joke so does louie
that's not how it works you know because
there's only a certain amount of [__]
things in this limited life that we live
the human experience is a finite one
so um
you gotta find your melody your rhythm
your delivery all those things you're
snow you're a snowflake
and find out what that is and that's
what makes you funny and your
perspective
on those things that have been done are
original and new at this point
and erica switzer when did you trust
yourself enough to start writing on
stage
good question
um
i had a show at bar echo at bar four in
brooklyn and park slope that was like
that was like my lab and it became a
pretty popular show in brooklyn a lot of
people would go you know hannibal uh ali
wong with a soda
nay i mean they were there like almost
every week i mean uh che
uh
everybody i mean there's so many people
would come through and rock that norman
was there probably the most and um
that's where i really started trusting
myself because it was my show i hosted
it i did a lot of time and that's where
i got comfortable kind of
writing on stage so i would say probably
around
you know between
2010 12 somewhere around there probably
about eight years ago nine years ago
is where i started to get comfortable i
don't know if i'm fully comfortable
because it's a tight rope walk every
time you know you're gonna bomb most of
the time you know you until you get it
right but you just have to be confident
and lead the crowd
and um
that's that's
that's uh
i i could lose that if i'm off stage for
a while so it's like that's all about
having your chops under you and just
like
being in shape just like an athlete just
you know training again being up doing
spots and that's where your confidence
comes because it's familiar up there
your mind is ready for it you feel sharp
you're in shape your mind's in shape
you know after the pandemic i mean i did
one weekend at stress factory in
october i hadn't been on stage at that
point
since what march right so it was like
march april may june july september
seven months i was nervous like i had
was when i first started doing comedy
and it's insane there were people
talking in the green room and i just
wanted them out of the green room
because i couldn't even listen to them
because i was so scared and trying to
think what i was going to do and it was
the whole week and every show i was
scared out of my mind so there you have
it
oh yeah i did i did a last year i did
one college because i was just like this
just pays too much for me to like i'll
get covered for this gig basically and
like the whole five hour drive there i
like have a set list i'm rehearsing it
for like five hours just like this is my
first time again it was really scary
yeah
did um
we talked about you quitting comedy
robin's ass about quitting comedy what
pulled you out of wanting to quit comedy
in those moments um
yeah donnell really um donnell rawlings
um
yeah are you open for me
yeah i opened for them on the chappelle
show tour him and
charlie murphy bill burr and christian
finnegan replaced billboard do five
minutes and sell his posters
and he let me go up in his room
donnell saw
he told me i was funny even though i was
not doing well so that's something
comics can see no you know that's why
these bookers all stink i mean people
talk about i hate to say this but like
i like bookers who are like humble and
know that their job is to book the
talent you know bernie brostein has an
old expression the legendary manager
agent he goes the reason why i was so
good is because i always had the best
talent it's it's show business not
business show so there are no legendary
anything except comics what makes you a
legendary booker or whatever is that you
get the best comics so no booker would
be able to tell a comic they were good
before they were they just that's just
what they you know you know how many
stories i've heard from good comics that
didn't get passed at certain clubs and
what those bookers said to them i mean
it's [__] hilarious
and you know and people like ah that
legendary book and i'm like look at who
they did in past and look at who they
did past are you [__] kidding me no
comic would do that no comic would ever
do that unless they were friends with
that person or they were [__] them
and they felt guilty okay comics put
funny people on and they know who funny
who who are who funny are who the funny
ones are and who aren't because they do
it it's game knows games it's like the
best coaches are you mo for the most
part have played at some point on some
level so um
donnell saw that me even when i was
horrible i mean i would go in his room
and bomb
but he told me i was funny and something
about someone who was so funny and
donnell is so funny telling me that i
was funny um gave me the confidence to
start again and you know i was like at
that point i'm like 30. so i was like
you know so i that i was doing comedy
once a week
and um it was really he pulled me in he
took me on the road he let me get up
every week and i started to develop love
from that then from there dustin
chaffman i give him a lot of credit he
started putting me up in his room uh
which was like a weekend night up at
broadway comedy club
and then i started doing these aaron
haber rooms and where he would have all
these barkers on and there'd be like one
i had one credit at the time when that
mattered i was on vh1's best week ever
originally
a few episodes so he would put me on and
they were like eight-minute sets i mean
god it was a grind and then i would do
bar rooms and then i started my own
rooms starting my own rooms was the best
bit of development but um it was really
john l that that pulled me back into it
and uh
i get i always give him credit for that
yeah that's what hot breath has become
the community is like a supportive and
positive environment to just like
develop as a comedian because like when
i started i was alone and confused it
was very competitive and negative so
it's like if they're if comics can just
not have to worry about that aspect and
just focus on getting good comedy will
just be better for it you know oh and
and that's uh that's a real positive
about this era it used to be guys were
competing for a few sets a few a few
half hours a few late night sets so it
was very competitive and that's what it
used to be guys used to [__]
you know
be negative and beat each other up to
keep their chops sharp it was a real
[__] knife fight it's
it's totally not that anymore man
it is there's room for everybody uh
comics can lift each other up you go on
my podcast i go on yours
uh you know there's
people it's not as a zero-sum game since
the humors are different some people may
like you they may like your friend more
um but those fans your friend will learn
about you and vice versa and eventually
although our egos don't want to admit it
people can only hear you so much
so it actually helps to be able to tell
people hey go listen to these people too
because they'll come back to you once
they get sick of those people too so it
actually elongates your career
um because it keeps you fresh there's
like an ever rotating
group of people checking a bunch of you
guys out
and it make everyone wins so it's like i
hate that [__] old school mentality i
hated it when it was necessary because
i'm the sensitive type although i do
understand it was necessary because it
was more competitive then but i that's
why i embrace this era so much it's like
nobody's a threat to you man
other comics can only help you and you
can only help other comics
amen well
giannis thank you so much for doing this
man um we we always end these with two
things one
your favorite comedy advice
you've ever gotten
and if you could look into the camera
and say your name and why people should
listen to hot breath
okay first people should listen to hot
breath
because it is a how to a master class
from comedians who are masters myself
not included
talking about
the craft so whatever field you're in
even if you're not a comedian you're
watching the process of how you get good
at something that obviously draws many
parallels in many fields
giannis papas thank you my friend and my
name is giannis pappas and the other
thing was what oh the sound piece of
comedy advice was actually from donnell
and i'll tell the quick story um this
was when chappelle show was like the
greatest thing on the planet
and it was i mean you couldn't imagine
how big it was you guys know it was
massive and neil brennan
came to his room donnell's and i was on
the show
and i just put way too much into it
right because of how big chapel she was
like oh my god in my mind i'm like neil
brennan's here um i got to do really
good and then i went up and just bombed
right and i was like afterwards i was
like donnell was like asking me why i
was so down whatever i was like i bombed
and i was like you know i was thinking
about neil brennan and like i wanted to
do good and donnell said the thing to me
i'll never forget he goes he goes ah son
he goes son because he says everything
yo what's up sean he goes yes son you
thinking about all the wrong things
and that stuck with me i was like oh
yeah all i got to think about is having
a good time and being funny
and that's it everything else falls into
place but
never think about who's in the crowd
never think just
have fun
i was i was kind the reason why i bombed
is i was thinking about the wrong things
and that carries over into all the
aspects of this game
be funny man it's show business business
show if you are funny if you get good
everything else will present itself to
you
even if that's you figuring out what
your show is what your internet [__] is
[__] be funny man and have fun doing
it
well there it is
hot breath the verse go forth
take here's another hot tip don't
sexually harass anybody because that'll
end your career quick ooh amen that's
what happened to history of hyenas y'all
you know they had to cancel chris real
quick
giannis is separating well where can i
listen to your new podcast and support
everything you got going on giannis
uh long days um you can find out on
youtube you can find it on all the audio
podcasts long days with giannis pappas
check it out
awesome well giannis pappas this has
been amazing hot breath the verse
we've done it again yo this i mean
this is the dopest comedy interview
podcast in the world and people will
find out eventually so thank you for
knowing about it right now hop brethren
and sister
and we will see you on the next one
thank you so much everyone have a good
day
you